what's up fellow art weirdos thank you
for coming my name's Tom um and thank
you for being a medium-sized cool
looking crowd I assume only cool people
hang out in regen CC seems true so far
and we get the chillest slot before the
uh the somewhat legendary question mark
party afterwards is my first and I've
been told last strange Loop so I'm
looking forward to whatever happens
tonight sounds cool has a good rep ation
um but thank you all for coming um I'm
going to do a um General presentation on
how I spent the last year um of my life
uh collaborating with a lot of other
people uh to make a bunch of weird art
with stable diffusion um that I am
really excited to share with you all it
has been a weird and inspiring Journey
um and I will try to emulate all the
reactions that I had while making and
seeing these images for the first time
as I go through them um but I'll I'll
kind of give you the general breakdown
of
um the timeline for how the year went
just kind of what we were working on who
I was working with how it went um what
we ended up building and the art that we
ended up making um and then I would
really love to uh get as quickly as
possible um I'll get my timer going uh
to just looking at some art and maybe
doing like actual Q&A time because I
would really love to know what you all
think of this and I have not gotten
enough feedback on any of this it's just
been kind of a whirlwind um so with all
that said uh this is an old school
presentation I taught art for a long
time like my lecture notes are what
appear on the screen so apologies but uh
it is nice because you can either read
or listen to me um uh and I will try to
not get stuck on any one slide for too
long but you got some multiple images
here most of these images are going to
be outputs from uh artist fine tunings
which I'll talk about in a second but
just to State the the goals as I kind of
did for the presentation I really just
want to share um how this year went and
what what we made what we built what we
learned um and kind of what's next for
the project uh and that will include but
not be limited to uh honing in a little
bit on textual inversion training I
won't get bogged down in the weeds too
much on that but if you know what that
is I will be referencing it um and
talking about how important it was to
project uh stable diffusion will of
course uh be covered to some extent um
gradio and hugging face deployments of
these sorts of projects will get covered
also um and then maybe most excitingly
uh or freshest in my mind um will touch
on these University of Alaska like
artist workshops that I got to do last
week um 5 days a week that was really
cool I'll get into the details of it and
then these two shows uh one of which is
up right now in Anchorage um and one
that's going to be hung uh in October
which is like next week or in two weeks
um down in Northern California where I
am from uh but the big guiding questions
that like I am keeping in mind I guess
like as I'm thinking about all this that
I would invite you all to keep in mind
too as you're looking at these images
um is initially just like can a
diffusion model make Fine Art and
unfortunately uh implied in that is the
question of what fine art is I would
invite you not to indulge that because
it's confusing and there's no answer to
it um but it looks weird as a sentence
if it just says art uh whether or not
that's a complex question to you might
differ um but it becomes a complex
question for me when Fine Art is in
there for whatever reason um and the
follow-up question of what it would mean
um just generally or for individual
artists for like the art world for
Humanity as a whole uh if these types of
generative models were capable of making
Fine Art and spoiler alert I think
you're you're always supposed to say uh
I don't have an answer to either of
those questions and this kind of
presentation I actually kind of do um
but
uh but we'll get to that I didn't put it
in writing I'll just I'll say it out
loud um a little bit on my background
just because it's uh it's not super
traditional for working in Tech um but I
started off studying engineering
foundations and Fine Art like tearing my
brain apart um at the same time at
different schools in San Francisco uh I
ended up um having a very wise
engineering Professor uh kindly suggests
that I drop out and go to Art School
which um it's interesting I wasn't
failing this class but uh I ended up
going to art school and kind of putting
engineering on pause um and discovered a
lot of teaching and pursued a master's
degree um at Yale which was the only
place I got into uh interestingly um
allowed me to start teaching after I
graduated from there and if you don't
know what BFA or MFA refers to in this
context um that means like actually
studying studio so I was like painting
and drawing and doing a certain amount
of mixed media like installation
experimental work um in both of those
programs um and then I ran away from New
York as fast as I could came back to
California and taught uh painting life
throwing and art history at a bunch of
colleges for about six years and change
um long enough for somebody to uh
actually tell me how much 10e track
positions pay um and then I immediately
started hanging out with my tech friends
in San Francisco again and they uh
openly and very warmly invited me into
um the completely different feeling
world of software development in this in
this new era of I it just felt like open
information and uh much more encouraging
than when I was in college so it was a
very positive transition and I got to
kind of sneak a lot of it into my um
into my uh curriculum that I was doing
with art students which was a lot of fun
before I kicked out on that uh but since
then I have gotten to work as a full
stack engineer in a number of capacities
um and I've gotten to teach uh software
engineering foundations for a little bit
too which was a lot of fun um and all of
that kind of like brought me up to uh
about a year ago when I went to the
recur Center um after somebody told me
they existed uh and I know there's a few
recurse people that I mean I heard about
this conference through them and I know
there's some out there uh but uh I had a
great experience there and that's when
this project began and I just threw in
that I'm an exhausted dad also just so
you all feel sorry for me on some level
or give me more credit for all this uh
and for whatever it's worth my studio
practice like personally um is still
rooted in like oil painting uh sometimes
large scale drawing although I don't
have time for that as much anymore mix
media installation when somebody gives
me the key uh to a weird gallery and
says do whatever you want um I did a fun
Visual Arts survey that's linked on my
website that I'll have up later uh a few
years ago that was a cool data
visualization um kind project and then I
just did the series of needlessly
accurate computer sculptures that I
sculpted by hand for some reason um and
that's a a wax cast of a clay sculpture
of an IBM 5150 there uh that has a
companion Apple 2 and c64 to go with it
so sort of a uh interesting historical
interlude but um but all of that is just
to set the context that uh within this
project I have found myself more
comfortable in the context of the the
astronaut horse project as a a
contributing artist and facilitator um
who ends up kind of pulling folks
together and reaching out to people and
Connecting People rather than taking
some lead role the one of the more
exciting things about this project has
been um the collaborative aspect of it
and I feel like I'm getting to play kind
of a role in that as an artist who's
making work that doesn't necessarily
have anything to do directly with uh
doing fine tunings with stable diffusion
um so a couple of slides kind of
squished together here just a stay on
track uh but um just to be very clear
about what astronaut horse is uh because
it's a confusing name um it is a bunch
of different things it's an open-ended
project but the core of it is just
trying to bring uh visual artists like
practicing visual artists and art
students um together to work on things
related to stable diffusion um with
researchers and software Engineers
mostly from the recurse center but
increasingly uh kind of reaching out of
that Community too for the tech side of
all that um and the product of those
collaborations so far has been kind of
uh pluralized so it's not necessarily
taking any one strong Direction it's
kind of in the Cambrian explosion phase
of trying different things out um but so
far these fine-tuned Concepts that are
um trained using textual inversion uh on
artist chosen images have formed the
core of the project it's been just the
most um I don't know like stimulating
for the artists and I think for the tech
folks and it continues to kind of be the
core of it and building on that um but
also along the way this live web
application happened um under a hugging
face Grant which is really cool that's
running certain aspects of the project
but uh most interestingly the like
actual artist fine tunings are all up
there and it gets like redeployed every
24 hours and adds more potentially um if
people have done more trainings but I'll
talk about that more in a bit um and
then a series of a growing series of
python uh collab notebooks for tools
that are involved in like the workflows
that we're kind of discovering that for
whatever reason aren't really
appropriate to put onto the deployed app
like doing the textual inversion
training which takes too long and locks
up the GPU so it's not something you'd
want to stick on an app um but a number
of other things too and all of these
pretty much everything I'm I'm
referencing here to is just linked on
the static site the astronaut. horse um
website too if you want to check any of
it out or use any of it but I'll plug
that later too uh and then recently um
it has the project has kind of
culminated into to a I'm just going to
call it a series even though there's
only two on the calendar right now um
but uh actual like in-person
semi-traditional art gallery shows uh
which I was very surprised anyone was
interested in and which I did not really
solicit uh but that that is another
interesting aspect that's happening more
in real time because again there's a
show up right now in Anchorage and
another one going up in October um and
this wacky Discord server has become a
part of the project as just a place for
um the art folks and recer Center folks
and Tech folks to overlap and actually
be able to converse somewhat but uh
primarily it's just a place for me to um
abuse Discord servers and dump hundreds
and hundreds of images um every time the
fancy strikes me onto somewhere that's
not my computer uh and also somewhere
that can be accessed by other people um
and these inperson workshops that go
along with the with the gallery shows
seemingly that's probably how it's going
to keep working for now um and just to
be very clear astronaut and horse if you
have not seen the kind of ubiquitous
benchmark image of an astronaut riding a
horse as a way of showing off how
amazing um kind of diffusion models in
general but definitely stable diffusion
is at generating um realistic
unimaginable images that's where that
term is from um maybe you've seen it if
not check out the stable diffusion uh
website or the Wikipedia page for stable
diffusion there's always a good
astronaut horse on there um and I don't
need to get into the Weeds on my time at
the recur Center necessarily but all
those dates are just up there to kind of
remind me that I came into the recar
center with completely different
intentions of like building out a weird
useless like Instagram alternative or
continuing to develop this zenbot that
is still like a side project that I
maintain and use a lot um and uh in line
with how you're supposed to experience
rehear Center uh did not realize what I
was actually going to focus on until I
was about halfway through the program
and then very rapidly got involved in
working with stable diffusion which had
was coming out and developing like uh
kind of at the same time the timelines
overlapped just coincidentally and then
chat gbd came out which just plugged
more energy into it but didn't have
anything directly to do with the project
um and I'm going to say check out fast
AI multiple times during this
presentation because it gets me out of
having to do in-depth technical
explanations but uh if you don't know
what fast AI is check it out free
lectures amazing lecture Jeremy Howard
and just absolutely inspiring
explanations of um stable diffusion and
topics related to
it so so with that said my timeline
trying to keep it like within sort of a
story structure here when I was at
recurse when I discovered or was exposed
to stable diffusion from some other
recursor uh and started working through
fast AI part two um which is was being
released in real time at that time like
week by week lectures and was focused on
reimplementing stable diffusion with the
python standard Library which is a
really crazy cool thing to be doing and
um because everybody is really into rust
at the recurse center or was at that
time we were trying to do it in Rust uh
it was a doomed project from the start
but we had a lot of fun um initially
getting into it and discovered very
quickly that the lectures were just
super uh Illuminating and worth going
through regardless of uh of our broken
rust implementation dreams um but with
with that timeline in mind of like us
learning about this stuff at this time
this this is the appropriate time to
just like shout out what stable
diffusion is if you are completely
unfamiliar with it I will not pretend to
be able to lecture um as knowledgeably
as again like the fast AI lectures and
others uh but I will at least describe
it um in the most General sense uh in
the way that I do to like art students
which is to describe it as a um text to
image generative model uh like um Mid
Journey or dolly or you know tools
within the Adobe suite that have been
integrated uh in its normal use case you
give it text and by bringing that text
into a math space and Performing machine
learning uh built processes on um the
the encoding in that math space you can
bring it into another uh format of
encoding that you can decode back out
into an image space and within that
process kind of core to the description
the diffusion part of stable diffusion
is this idea of like d noising an image
um iteratively not all at once but
chopping up this process into into steps
that allow an image to gradually Den
noise from a static starting point and
that's one of the more interesting
aspects of it and uh and a couple of our
little tools that we built um showcase
that D noising process but that's sort
of like in a nutshell how I explain it
to artists if anybody is like totally
unfamiliar and textual inversion in a
nutshell is um is I don't know if I call
it a more complex process but it builds
on uh stable diffusions like core
training which is an open source set of
images that um that I reference in here
too the Layon uh training images which
I've never said out loud but maybe that
was correct um which you can peruse
freely like I said there's some really
cool tools linked on the Discord for uh
perusing those in a similar way to uh
how stable diffusion kind of views its
image sets indirectly um but I would
encourage you to check that out uh but
as we were well the the explanation for
textual inversion training is that
building on that training that is
trained on you can pretend it's the
whole internet it's totally not it's a
very like select um bit of the internet
even if it's a large bit uh but textual
inversion takes in a very small number
of images um chosen by whoever is
running the training like five to 15
images um and then through a process of
uh of essentially like embedding those
into its normal process for diffusing an
image out identifies patterns within
that uh that allows it the process to
essentially create a word that doesn't
exist or an embedding for a word that
doesn't exist that you can then
reference in a normal text prompt so if
you gave it five images of like yourself
which was the first thing a couple of
folks did at recur Center um you would
essentially be saying like hey whatever
I am whatever I look like make up a word
for that that you can understand in the
context of all your other training um
and then I can use that in a normal
sentence structure for a text embedding
um it's very interesting uh and I'll
talk about it more like when we have
some examp examples up of uh what ended
up coming out of that but again in a
nutshell those are kind of the two Core
Concepts and there's some interesting
limitations Associated um with Sable
diffusion that we noticed really early
on at this time when we were learning um
with fast AI uh but the most interesting
one um that was in part why we ended up
like going with this name of astronaut
horse uh was that the uh horse cannot
ride the astronaut I don't know if
anybody's ever like tried to plug that
in absolutely not not with photoshop's
tool not with any
uh open source or um or for-profit
implementation of a diffusion process
that I have seen um and when you pull
over if you pull over to search through
the training images you will see very
quickly that the reason it is able to
these models are able to uh create
images of astronauts riding horses is
because we trained them with hundreds
and hundreds of images uh that humans
made graphic designers and illustrators
and Painters made of astronauts riding
horses not a big secret um and if you
reverse that very few if any I never
found any image in um in that particular
training Set uh that uh showcased a
horse writing an astronaut um but it
would be a worthy a worthy subject for
an artist to pursue at some point and
flood a data set with so that we can get
past this uh very serious roadblock in
the evolution of our species um and my
big moment with it too uh because I am
an art history nerd was noticing that
all of these uh Demos in fast Ai and
elsewhere showcase like um van go and
vermier the painters uh disconnected
painters but both European historical
painters um as again sort of like
Benchmark tests like look I can make a
picture of like a teddy bear as if van
go painted it um I can make a painting
or I can have this stable diffusion
process make a painting of girl with a
Pearl Earring the famous for Mirror
painting but it's a dog instead of a
girl and getting really amazing output
and I my first thought was they have an
order of magnitude difference between
them in terms of how much work they made
like vermier has maybe like 30 Works
attributed to him and Van go has like
hundreds and hundreds um there's 300 is
too small but I think it's like 300
paintings um the last time I was diving
into a book on him uh but that seemed
odd to me because they seemed equally
capable and again searching through the
data set I uh or the the training image
set I did not quite know what to make of
the sort of uh retrospectively obvious
fact that um the reason that these
models are good at doing these things is
because we just showed them how to so
even though vermier only made like a few
paintings in his lifetime and definitely
none where a dog was dressed up like a
woman with a Pearl Earring um hundreds
and hundreds of humans have imitated
verm mir's painting style students
artists etc etc and posted them on the
Internet uh which uh allowed them to end
up in this training set and I I don't
know like what it breaks down to in
terms of how many people have imitated
Van Go versus verir but um essentially
there's enough images just painted by
people who are not verir that they end
up having like a basically comparable
representation in the data set and
capability and a diffusion model um and
then the last sort of section that has
to be mentioned even though it oddly has
not come up with any of the artists I
have talked to uh is just the general
question of ownership and copyright um
and first of all it is it this project
never felt like it was in danger of
crossing a line because there was never
any interest in trying to make this a
money oriented project um and the goal
in all my conversations with visual
artists was to build Artist Artist
agency critical agency just meaning like
uh a kind of ownership over this process
feeling like they understand how it
works and can critique the process um
and not feel like subject to it like
it's a sort of like magic entity that
they couldn't possibly like break into
or understand or have any agency over um
and with that goal in mind I don't think
we ever like it didn't feel like we ever
strayed uh towards um towards murky
Waters with uh ownership and especially
the state the project is in now um we've
kind of figured out processes that just
feel more academic and experimental and
just up to the artists to use in any way
they see fit uh but it's kept the
project on track and and it kind of got
sort of cemented by this uh this
phrasing that these images belong to
everyone and no one which I think the
artists have responded really well to
and and again if if there's any one
interesting thing to note there um it's
that it just has not come up uh and I
have been sort of waiting for it to come
up so maybe somebody can ask a really
good question about it um and see how
much I've actually thought about
it uh the next phase of this um after
sort of identifying the textual
inversion training was really capable
and learning more about stable diffusion
doing some implementations uh somebody
again at reur Center um randomly
mentioned uh that gradio was a thing
that existed maybe some of you have
encountered it um but but in a nutshell
it's a really simple way a uh it's a
python library that um creates a very
simple process for making uh user
interfaces for these types of projects
so if you have a working collab notebook
or a working python notebook um it's
fairly easy to just slap a gradio
application onto it it's oversimplifying
it a little bit um but it is very easy
to use and just make like a an interface
like automatic 11-11 if anybody's messed
around with that um can be used in this
way with just a gradio interface slapped
on top of a bunch of complex uh
processes in a python notebook um and
then hugging face spaces also uh came
onto our radar well being exposed to
gradio I was doing a a gradio
implementation of um of not the actual
like textual inversion training but just
some like demo stable diffusion
processes for a recurse uh presentation
and then hugging face spaces just came
up hugging face owns them so it's not
surprising but that again uh just
creates a very easy process for taking a
gradio application that is maybe working
essentially on top of a collab notebook
and then tossing that into a deployed
space that you can actually use on the
internet and have other people use and
share openly which is not something you
can do when you're just using radio um
with collab so some of you may have
encountered hugging face spaces um it is
a very cool uh aspect of what they
provide for the machine learning
community and it's very easy to use but
I found out very quickly in doing that
presentation um I decided to just go for
it and see what happened I've never
deployed like a GPU Hardware um project
and I immediately got a bill for many
hundreds of dollars that I did not have
uh because I was very unemployed at
recurse Center which is uh the way of
the recurse center um and I wrote them a
very nice uh sad sounding email about
how I was a former teacher at rer Center
and I didn't have hundreds and hundreds
of dollars and I did this for a demo um
promoting their their products and
services or whatever and they wrote me a
very very very nice email back um
immediately uh negating the bill but
also inviting me to apply to a GPU grant
program that they had apparently
available that just didn't come up in my
initial research kind of like buried
under their deployment settings a little
bit um but yeah they gave us this little
GPU Grant we gave them a little write up
for it and it's been running uh on that
grant for almost a year um and it has
just made every interaction I've had
with hug face has just been super
positive um really good communication
and uh troubleshooting and just seems
generally like a super supportive
community so thank you hugging face
wherever you are uh for continuing to
give us free GPU
time um so then getting to kind of the
core of it after that application was
set up it immediately like seemed
obvious that you could based on how we
were um running these textual inversion
trainings and then loading the concepts
or the tokens into a standard stable
diffusion pipeline um which is what you
have to do to actually continue to um
have those tokens be like available for
a text prompt you have to load them in
it's somewhat complicated to like
integrate them into a stable diffusion
pipeline but it's all very well
documented um and it was something that
it was immediately clear could be
integrated into uh the live application
that we had which was super exciting
because now it was something that I
could potentially share with these
visual artists that I had started to
talk to um after doing the training like
we had played around with the idea of
just like doing trainings and giving
artists like a bunch of images but that
felt like a weird service to be
providing that wasn't like sustainable
and didn't really give artists like the
agency in that relationship um but this
suddenly became a scenario where we
could facilitate the artist running a
training um and then have it be loaded
onto that live application let them do
whatever they wanted with it and kind of
along the way maybe like expose them to
a little bit of confidence using collab
notebooks and so on which uh is always
an uphill battle with visual art folks
for whatever reason um me included but
uh we began going through this this
still ongoing series of um of artist
trainings uh using textual inversion we
ended up working with stable diffusion 2
which I can talk about later um but that
has actually been like a very functional
uh version of stable diffusion for us
and um we haven't hit any limitations
with it that have been problematic so uh
with the exception of this one which was
the first training on stable diffusion
one all the rest of the ones that you'll
see for the most part are running off of
two um but this process is still
essentially like a traditional reach out
to an artist somebody friend of a friend
or somebody that whose show someone has
seen um trying to have like a studio
visit like over Zoom with them or a
phone call um explaining the project in
as brief a way as possible um without
letting it get too overwhelming for them
and letting them know that uh whatever
type of ownership they're interested in
having over the images is Theirs to
Define which is an important part of
that conversation to let them know if
they don't like what happens in this
process we just just delete it all and
pretend it never happened um there there
was a kind of workshopping period of
trying to figure out how to articulate
that quickly um but then once the
training uh is complete off of 5 to 15
images that they've selected either of
their work or work that inspires them um
we then run as many batch prompts as
they want and show them how to use this
batch prompter that's just a python
notebook to get several hundred images
uh out of that training to kind of
figure out what it's good at um and then
and build sort of a knowledge base for
being able to use it just on the live
application which it's set up now to
just like autoload every time it
redeploys um so yeah then just kind of
explaining to them they can use it
however they want and if they want to
have it removed at any point they can uh
if they're not comfortable with it for
some reason and then just seeing what
they do with it um and this first
training we did uh is kind of stuck in
my mind um it was kind of impromptu this
artist was nice enough to send me every
image he ever made uh every painting he
ever made and we at the recurse center
there was just a group meeting about
something else and we just randomly
picked out a small handful of them um
and then ran a few hundred images out of
that and i' had never seen uh the output
from this kind of training like in Mass
before from an actual artist input um
and I was really surprised by um by the
reaction that I had and like what I was
noticing about what it was good at first
of all it was not good at wrote
imitation of the artist style it wasn't
really it didn't seem like interested
quote that's not a proper term to apply
to a soulless piece of software but it
did not seem interested in trying to
figure out what the subject matter was
for the artist like specifically and
imitating that it didn't seem interested
in just copying the same kinds of colors
and marks it seemed like it immediately
picked up on more nuanced patterns in
the artist's work like that that was
immediately clear and my my artist
teacher brain clicked on immediately uh
because these were works that looked
like you could hang them up on a wall
and have a really good discussion about
them in a class like in a traditional
academic critique of artworks um and
more than that it seemed like it was
focusing or focusing sort of uh covering
a breadth of images that were diversely
representing slight variations of
nuanced aspects of the artist's work
like color use color pallet use um like
sort of other formal qualities like
composition um and even subject matter
and in this one in particular uh the way
lines were used in this artist work
were I think he had just discovered a
process of like overlaying lines on top
of paintings and sometimes underneath
but the way lines were used in the
images that it output felt to me like a
visual articulation of a really good
critique that you would have like in art
school if you presented that body of
work to a group of professors or an
individual Professor sort of like a
golden moment that could have that could
come out of that hypothetical
interaction is them pointing out that
you were just using lines to cover
things or just using lines to out
outline things and the variation of line
use sort of looked like uh like a visual
version of the sentence or sort of like
a critique that you could use lines as
Windows or you could use lines as W as
Windows into other spaces or they could
open up into threedimensional forms eyes
could be coming out of lines or behind
lines they could be bars there was
something really really interesting
about that because it felt so so quickly
like it could stand in for what is one
of the most important parts of like how
art Education Works now which is that
critique relationship with an
instructor um and there was also this
hint uh really early on that this this
seemed like a more of a vehicle for
collaboration um than just for like the
mass production of an artist style of
work because it it did not look like the
artist's work um it looked enough like
the artist work to be interesting to the
artist and to me and other people who
found the artist work interesting for a
lot of the same reasons but um it did
not seem like it belonged to them it
seemed like it was a collaboration with
stable diffusion's larger uh image set
that it was trained on so I.E like
basically the internet which is a big
collaborative project um and that became
a really exciting aspect of it too that
we're still building on um and this
potential for like historical
exploration I'll touch on later too so
uh again trying to trying to move
through the narrative here um but we
ended up expanding the features on the
app to kind of current state and
integrating like implementing some
papers that people would find at the
recurse center um getting like a couple
of control net tabs working that uh have
played an interesting sort of like side
role in potential processes for artists
especially like making these animated
gifts using different seeds um different
static seeds overlaid onto uh control
net images to produce like slight
variants of the same image over and over
again um so a bunch of those on the
Discord if you want to check them out um
making sure the AO autoloader worked for
the new artist Concepts that was kind of
like a tricky thing to pull but ended up
uh being pretty reliable so that they're
in there automatically um and artists
can run those trainings independently
whenever they want off of that notebook
if they're comfortable doing it um this
tab that is called artbot right now for
lack of a better term um but I kind of
started thinking of it as like a
compound token uh Tab and it's one of
these benefits one of the interesting
benefits of continuing to work with um
textual inversion training rather than
like Laura models um is that you can
like put more of them into one space
pretty easily and you can do that with a
lot of different kinds of fine tunings I
believe um but they integrate with each
other really successfully and that's
that's kind of it's fast forwarding a
little bit we played around with it
early on at this stage but it's become
sort of the focal point of the project
for me at least it seems like the most
capable process for consistently making
things that feel like Fine Art again
whatever that means um the manual seat
entry too I kind of throw up their uh
because I I do want to give this
presentation to some artists also and I
I want to make sure to point out that
that was very easy thing to implement
but a very important part of the app for
uh again like encouraging artists to
learn about this process um and then we
continue to build out the python
notebooks for stuff that wouldn't fit
into uh the app or weren't appropriate
to deploy into the app um but uh the
batch prompting tool that we have that
gets used a lot and um what else have I
got there uh like breaking down the D
noising process a latent space
interpolation animation uh tool that
isn't showcased here but um but was a
pretty cool paper implementation for
animating movements through latent space
uh that's on the Discord also if you
want to check them out they're very cool
um and then in upscaler we had to uh
Implement a little upscaler for or a
batch upscaler for getting images ready
for uh for these exhibitions because
they had to be printed larger than their
um their native resolution which is uh
768 or 1024 depending on um what kind of
pipeline you're running for stable
diffusion and again all those notebooks
are available on uh on the workshops tab
of the static site so this is like the
most exciting part for me because I just
did it and I'm super exhausted from
doing it uh but um we got this
opportunity through one of the uh one of
the collaborations we did um with one of
the artists which ended up being like
kind of our our most interesting early
uh fine tuning that had like an
emergence moment you'll see the images
I'll Point them out but they they've
been these sort of like bizarre alien
forums um you can talk a little bit
about that uh when we have an image up
for it but uh that artist um connected
us with uh doing this first physical
exhibition up in Anchorage of all places
at this really beautiful space um
associated with the University of Alaska
and uh they hung it uh extremely well it
was like a beautiful hang we kind of
gave them like free free creative power
to uh hang it however it seemed
appropriate I was really curious what
they would decide on um but got a bunch
of big prints and print files for them
with that batch upscaler and uh they got
some beautiful prints made that looked
um fantastic up close even though it's a
different uh stable diffusion process to
get them upscaled that doesn't integrate
those fine tunings um but they looked
amazing the impact of seeing them on the
wall was really unexpected uh I had seen
physical printouts before but seeing
them in an art space the the short
conclusion of it is that it immediately
felt like artart was no novelty feeling
to it there was an interesting aspect to
like knowing that there was this uh very
important like complex process behind
the production of the images but that's
kind of true of like any fine art that
you end up being engaged with is there's
a process and a context um but there
really was no moment of like this
doesn't feel like art uh walking in and
uh I ended up doing workshops up there
with the students and folks from the
community um that they advertised to uh
for 5 days we just did them every night
to see where they went and every night
uh it was it was sort of like a another
renewed surprise of not having anybody
respond by sort of like obsin thinking
it wasn't art or having that
conversation getting into like an
ownership copyright conversation which
would have been interesting also um but
definitely noteworthy that nobody um
seemed to be taking the position of not
feeling like it was Art and I'm not sure
it's art still uh but it felt like art
um and that's really that's really the
only metric that can guide you uh we can
talk a little bit more about what that
means to me at least uh towards the end
here but yeah it was just a really
fantastic opportunity and the energy
around it with the workshops was equally
fantastic and it was great having um not
just art students and artists show up to
it but we had a bunch of uh scientists
uh affiliated with the university show
up also or a few I should say I don't
know what a bunch technically is
um but really interesting perspectives
good energy um and and it ended up
feeling like a really nice excuse to
expose art students specifically to
learning python being comfortable with
collab notebooks these things that can
be very empowering but also very
intimidating from the perspective of a
young person who um is trying to figure
out how the heck they're going to
survive in this world and also make art
um so that felt like a very positive
aspect of it also
um and then before again we we go into
just like looking at some art which is
probably the point of this uh
presentation ultimately um and getting
some Q&A time in maybe uh for whatever
it is worth it just felt important for
me to like kind of go through the
thought process of what my studio
practice is related to this stuff I'm
I'm sort of actively soliciting other
artists to describe the same thing to me
but as of right now um I have noticed
that what I will end up doing when I
have studio time again I have a
three-year-old and I I have a software
job so studio time is is good but always
limited uh no matter what but I will
generally like sit down do a new
training often based on um on open
images from specifically the Met museums
uh like Open Access uh site it's the the
site is just their whole collection but
the part of that collection that is open
access I'll I'll kind of explore those
feel like some sort of feedback Studio
inspirational feedback from a certain
time period um like these ones in the
middle were based off of a training that
was from uh some ancient near East uh
zodiac coins super super interesting
kind of stuff that's just like buried in
this massive um art collection at the
Met Museum and photographed and perhaps
very rarely looked at um but I'll do a
training with some set like that
potentially maybe a set of like my
drawings or paintings um or I will find
a new uh compound token or token pairing
through the live application that just
works it's like maybe 50/50 or one in
three that will just click it randomly
pairs token together and when it works
it interestingly seems to have like an
80 to 90% like efficacy rate like if it
works once uh at making something
interesting or inspirational it'll work
pretty consistently which is one of the
one of the interesting aspects of that
compound um token or compound concept
tab um and then I'll batch prompt out
like 500 to a th000 images I will
usually give them no text prompt except
the tokens um for those trainings uh
there's a really great Steven Wolfram um
write up I don't think it's blog post uh
technically but um but paper that he
posted about uh Alien Minds that
discusses amongst other things like the
importance of um of allowing these uh
these diffusion models to free associate
by not prompting them really cool write
up super articulate obviously it's uh
it's a very good read and contains other
stuff but um kind of backed up what I
was noticing which is that they seem to
want very minimal prompts or they would
do the most interesting things with
minimal prompts so I'll get like a
thousand of those I have started
actually just printing them out with a
little like um another collab tool that
just like toss together a giant PDF uh
to make a printer struggle really hard
to process and print out um and then
I'll just have those physically around
and when I'm having studio time it can
just be like sort of screenless going
through these proof sheets essentially
and finding interesting images sometimes
identifying one of them and running them
uh running that image along with its
seed through this uh seed cropping tool
that is kind of an interesting other
thing to discuss that
uh by just cropping parts of that static
seed off of the bottom just really kind
of lazily Andor cleverly uh creates
really interesting variants off of
individual images and manages to make
like if you find an image you like it
will produce nine or 10 or 15
interesting variants of that image that
you will also probably like um that's
available on the site too but it's it's
a it's an interesting one that um that
I'm still kind of trying to figure out
what to do with but uh sometimes I'll
run some images through that but
essentially I'll just make paintings and
drawings like from those images they
make me want to make art um and I for
right now don't feel like it has to be
more complicated than that and it feels
very much like making still life
drawings or observational like landscape
drawings except that it feels involved
in something very interesting
technically um and yeah it doesn't feel
like it has to be much more complicated
than that for now for me at least and
I'm curious like as as more artists
spend time with these like what they
will uh conclude on also um and again I
mentioned the sort of like historical
explor exploration or critical Insight
collaboration so on um that is all in
there too in terms of like what the
motivations are to continue working with
these um but specifically uh there's
there's a couple of trainings that are
interesting from that historical
standpoint like like the coins of those
cave paintings they feel like they're uh
meaningfully filling in sparse
constellations of preserved art
historical like artifacts so like
there's only X number of preserved C
paintings like maybe you know a few
hundred like in on the planet that have
been really well preserved but there is
every um every needed bit of evidence to
imply that there were like thousands
thousands millions of K paintings being
painted outside not in caves on bodies
um and in caves that just haven't been
discovered or weren't preserved that
existed that we'll never know about and
that was that was a feeling with that
cave painting training that it really
looked to me like a meaningful attempt
to to show me images of the other C
paintings that we will never actually be
able to see um and there was there was a
feeling of like rigor in that it didn't
feel like meaningless free association
it felt like a real uh attempt um on the
part of stable diffusion that process to
to make uh very educated guesses at what
those other artifacts might look like if
they did exist um so in terms of what's
next uh for this project we've got the
show in October um that we're going to
do like a very different kind kind of
installation with um that'll be a little
more like insano overwhelming um with a
lot more images up to see how that feels
it's a similar Siz space It should be
very interesting uh we're probably going
to scale it down to do like weekly
artist workshops and um try really
specifically to reach out to faculty um
like at UC Davis and other colleges that
are uh in our little area in Northern
California um we're still experimenting
with uh implementing or getting a
meaningful tool built out uh using
the the kind of latest sexiest version
of stable diffusion sdxl um and these
Laura models that you may have like
encountered but they you in short they
feel like they are very very good at
doing what everybody wants these things
to do which is illustrate things well um
and I have not yet gotten uh a sort of
sdxl side project to be really good at
making images that can take a lot of
different formats on like that can
Embrace sort of like this photographic
weirdness that I don't know in
conversations at least seems to uh be
attributable to just the fact that these
are trained on like the raw internet
sort of not really um rather than being
uh pushed really hard towards uh
illustrative um capabilities but um but
that's continue also and then my
personal plan is just to make more human
art it's I I really like that my
takeaway from all this work has just
been wanting to make analog work more
not less I really didn't know how that
was going to feel I've spent a lot of
time working um these tools and this app
and so on uh and it feels like the
payoff there was there was some
insecurity I think I had about like not
making work that I felt like I should be
making the the work that really feels
like traditional artwork and I am just
personally very happy that that's kind
of where it ends up getting left for me
but I'm also trying to find uh more
opportunities to like show the work do
workshops and uh also folks to
collaborate with or or opportunities to
get um some aspects of this Pro
closer to like the machine learning and
research side of all of it it's a it's a
common problem with stable diffusion
projects and a lot of machine learning
projects that you don't want it to get
stuck in like a push button mode um and
yeah that's kind of like a goal mid or
long term so just reasing those big
questions before looking at some images
uh to have them in my mind and perhaps
yours also uh can these diffusion models
make Fine Art what would it mean if they
could and my little sub questions of
asking if it would change the way we
could we thought about collaboration if
it could change the way that we thought
about artistic ownership and authorship
um if it could change the way that we
thought about ourselves as like an
artmaking species um or just about
creativity in general so some subth
thoughts to that but then we can just
look at some
work and these are in roughly
chronological order so that's a c
painting
one this was a training that was um an
artist that uh produced very few Works
in their lifetime that a few of us uh
from reirse went to see a show of and
one of the most like amazing trainings
we
did again feeling like kind of an art
historical constellation filler for an
artist that didn't make that much work
this was uh this was from that
University of Alaska artist um and all
the training images used for these can
be found through the static site also
they're they're linked and they're also
just on hugging face um in their
Concepts Library which is the a lot of
private Concepts I guess but it's open
for the most part and you can see what
images were used to train Concepts but
that previous one and this one were the
first time an artist had given us just
images that inspired them from their
Studio like random magazine clippings
that they found on the street or weird
pieces of strange jewelry that they
found or fossils that they had dug up um
out in Alaska specifically with this
artist and I really thought it was going
to be like a garbage in garbage out
scenario of like bad photographs would
make for a very bad training and it was
shocking how good those trainings were
at making images that were that seemed
greater than the some of their parts in
terms of the training images but also
just extremely interesting for the same
nuanced reasons that I was interested
and other people were interested in that
artist work a coin training um and then
moving into these like compound Concepts
or compound training ones where you have
more than one
token
and I also I kind of promised I would I
would imitate my my reactions to these
when they appeared at 2: in the morning
in front of me um I think this one I I
said something like what are you
serious
[Music]
what are you kidding me especially
knowing who the artists were that were
that uh that it was trained on it was
like what come on that's
ridiculous like what are you kidding
this like I want to own that I believe
is what I said and the seed is listed on
these to for whatever reason I just
started recording
them I think this one was just like a
what like what do what do I even do with
that like I I want it but I don't know
why oh come on that's not I couldn't I
can't make a painting that good that's
ridiculous I don't think I had a
reaction for this one except I want it
it's just a it's just a good painting I
don't know um
and obviously this could go on and on as
like hard drives and hard drives worth
of these um but I try to keep it limited
so maybe we can have some Q&A time
here's my little thank you list uh for
the
collaborators um both Anonymous and not
Anonymous that contributed art to this
and work and energy and inspiration and
guidance um it has really been a
community project and the most rewarding
Community project I've ever done with
other artists and Tech folks um my
contact info up there
uh and a uh explicitly stated invitation
to anybody that wants to collaborate
this is very much set up to just
collaborate with openly if you hop onto
the Discord anybody um probably me can
explain the process but it's also fairly
self-explanatory you can pop open a
textual inversion training collab
notebook you can run it for free you can
train a concept for free on collab for
in a few hours and then it'll get loaded
automatically onto um onto that live
application and then you can make weird
art in response to it so uh I will again
just encourage you if you want to join
the Discord and check out more images
they're all on there you can just lurk
uh you could also share anything you're
doing I'd be curious to keep in contact
with any of you um and then I have this
repeat info up there with a
placeholder um how much time do we
have off okay so Q&A follow up with me
if you have any questions I'd love to
talk about any or all of this and uh
thank you all for
coming
[Applause]